有如何成为你过人,给大家分享一个特别真实,特别简单粗暴,使用的方法,我们每周四晚上都会有一个方态,就创业之外啊,对吧,你也朋友,今天晚上放弹的是国合,聊的时候的话,国合就提到到一个现象,特别呢,他不是做的,但是为吗,有时候出门的时候就真常被人碰,然后我是,我是你的粉丝,国合就特别不摄影,说我就是个普通人,对吧,
我不习惯,然后我跟他说,我说,哥哥你知道吗,你确实实实实,我也是,我知道,对吧,但是你又确实实个女人,为什么,因为我们大部分从小的生活经历,就是,小学出中,大学,然后完了以后,就是为了找到一个好工作,你知道吗?
准能力的好多年就是被他找到一个好工作,就是他了思想的认知是被言中限制的,对,站在我们现在这个角度看,其实就是个思维方式的不同,所以方式一遍,人怎么就不一样,或者哪怕稍微动一下,这个人生也就不一样了,就从我们叫做上看,就是这个样子的,但是你知道吗,就是这个思维想变化有多难,就卖出那一小步,到底有多难,我这样天有一个非常深刻的认知,
就是我们是没有很多那些人特别爱学习,其实也很情愿,也很想改变,他就是不知道该怎么变,他不知道该怎么卖出第一步,就卖出第一步的时候,他会有非常非常多的限制,就很多人可能一辈子都卖不开,但是在我们看,就非常能简单,所以我想给大家分享,就下了过以后就突然想给大家分享,一个特别使用的特别简单的话,怎么做,我告诉你,第一个事情,第一件事情就去做一些小事,
去完成一些很小的事,最好自己律数能挤的事,这个事的话如果发展好了,他别人可能会需要什么东西,让他们可能需要说,不要浅肺,不要被漂亮,我需要被别人尊重,我需要一个钱,大部分人的需求,很正常对不对,那么我觉得你就可以做一样很小的事情,什么意思,比如说我之前,他不可以等你可以,
但是不要给自己听那么好的方向,我要这么一百万的方向太高了,你们小一点,是我先这么一半半件事,这个把我自己,考我的能力这一半件事,是我一上来做一个百万,一百万的阿伟能不能把并能没那么高,我做一个一万的一万的,这个分四可不可以,所以各位,首先要做成一件小事,认真的把它做好,第二块的话,再给大家一个小建议,就是,你一定要靠近一些,相对来说,不要用手,
对吧,比如说我其实站在那儿的便宜,就是你,我到北达胖城里段时间,雖然我的文化,当时素质,不像人家,真正考上去的人的素质,但你每天生活在那个地方,旁边的人都是那样的人,你会发现你不一样的,你不一样的,就在你根本上你也是不一样的,那里吧,所以为什么有时候你要靠近一些,不要优秀的人呢,如果你在一些小城市,或者你在一些传动行,我真的很介意你,就是,
想办法去接近一些相对来说,有时候的人,就晚上的时候,少说爱些短视频,少大一会儿有意义,多接触一些相对来说的人,他会过一些,你就慢慢嘛,就有时候说是我个场域,你发现这个场里,这也啥也学习,那也啥也学习的,那个是也做的,做的什么小事,那个也是做的小事,哪怕你不想做,你会为我协在里边,你会放钱,你就会发现做什么人群嘛,你记得不放点手,你跟人群走走走,突然发现,你能理由一次吧,所以呢,
两个事,第一个是你尽可能接近一些,第二个是认真做好一件小事,记住一件小事,不要一伤来有什么一百吧,不要一伤来有真的,做了百万大的一,做一百万次,一万块钱,可不可以,对吧,然后认真的把这件事做好,如果你不知道怎么做,怎么办,我告诉你,最近的方法就是模仿,就是人类的,你要说别的不会,你就会模仿,对吧,因为有些说我不会做的嘛,我换别人做什么,我就这么做,所以你看,有哪些人生命,
那有哪些人,或者能接近那些人,他在你眼里算是什么的人,但是你不能够得着,好像他做的事情你也能做,我举个例子,就是你觉得我还可以,那很简单啊,我做什么你做什么,我拍个认识你也拍个认识,对吧,然后我写书你写书,我写小策的,也写小策刺,我每天看书都帮你,也开书都帮,我每天去做成一件小策刺,写一段小问题,你也去写得小问题,我每天介绍什么,你也去写点什么,好不好,就是,就是做什么,
从一件小策,打一件小策,做成了,然后你再做成,第二件小策,注意啊,做这个事的过程中,一定要不断的,就是往外分享,一定要有一个自己的自媒体,我不管是短时间,一定要有自己的自媒体,好,你就去做这个事情,认真把一件小策做好,然后就不要认识,当你有一万分四的时候,你会发现你的自媒已经不一样了,
你有两万分四的时候,你会发现,你好像有点感觉到,当你有十二分四的时候,你走个大街上突然有人跑不来说,我是你的粉丝,你看看你的合作有,你就知道我今天晚上,跟你说的是什么了。